president biden on capitol hill moments
ago trying to salvage his massive 3.5
trillion dollar socialist agenda the
president not sounding too confident
after stepping out of the meeting
i'm telling you we're going to get this
done
it doesn't matter when
it doesn't matter whether it's in six
minutes six days or six weeks
we're gonna get it done
come on man
you knocked the party 50 50. i got it
biden forced to step in because the
democrats dumpster fire has been burning
all week and shows no signs of simmering
down
instead of coming together the party
can't stop bickering over how far left
his plan should go
senator joe manchin said 1.5 trillion is
his number is that sufficient for the
both of you
who is he taking the money from that's
my question he does not need any of the
resources that we're talking about i
don't want to suggest that the
progressives are wrong they haven't been
legislators most of them for a very long
period of time and a lot of the
activists and tried to get things in
other ways i've been a legislator for 44
years
i've got car my car is older than quite
a few of the progressives that's a
pretty good line so dan jackie heinrich
one of our reporters on capitol hill
just spoke to a democrat source who told
her that biden's visit just now nothing
burger
yeah that's the the chicken guy remember
him fried chicken yeah the character
that guy here's the problem obviously
this is a cesspool of government ways
government as i said yesterday and i'll
say again can do nothing right um nobody
at the table can tell me everything they
touch they burn to the ground um it's a
cesspool you're better off taking your
money and burning it than giving it to
the government because everything they
give it to they destroy so this is kind
of like sadly uh you know a win for
republican politics but a loss for the
country by the way if it passes biden
destroys the country inflation goes
crazy he decimates home health care
everything else the government
introduces its disgusting tentacles into
right if it doesn't pass his legislation
goes down in flames richard you're
looking at me i assume you're going to
show to me one area where government
does anything right that's okay that's
cool um i will disagree with you
strongly but the one thing before i jet
on this that's really important whenever
you ask a democrat this question i'll
never give you an answer you go hey i
asked him on my show unfiltered
shameless plug by the way but i said to
one of the democrats what's the red line
for debt where the united states goes
into like potential de facto bankruptcy
they go i don't know and you don't know
either i go yeah that's my point like
don't you think like we should probably
like take it a little slow now that we
have no idea like when the de facto
bankruptcy comes because it happened in
argentina and venezuela and elsewhere
it's not like this is unprecedented but
they just keep spending you know and
it's an insult to drunken sailors
everywhere you know we have a drunken
sailor right here richard fowler please
respond to dan bongino's
assessment that it's just worthless to
spend 3.5 trill while we can't even keep
track of the money that's still going
out well number one i don't think it's
gonna i don't think that the final
bill's gonna end up being 3.5 trillion
dollars i think it's going to be a far
smaller amount uh number two uh i i
think that what i think what biden did
in this meeting that we just saw there
was he let some air out the room so the
actual legislators and the ways and
means committee can actually get down
and figure out how they come to some
semblance of a framework that allows all
the democrats to come together and vote
on this and i think it's worth pointing
out that both in the bipartisan
infrastructure bill that passed the
senate with 17 republican votes as well
as what will be this reconciliation bill
what you're going to find is programs
that will actually reinvest in america
right we are we are the world's largest
yeah well wait a minute now we are the
world's largest economy uh and there are
things that we need to do that are the
other economies have us beat if we're
trying to compete with the world we are
the only developed country that doesn't
have high speed rail right we're the
only developer
well why would you say that because it's
a boondoggle
california when japan and europe has
high schools those are tiny countries
those are tiny countries we'd rather fly
itself we have airplanes better okay
sure um we also have crumbling we also
have crumbling bridges we have
uh airports that are outdated and
falling apart we can go on and on and
talk about all week we can fix the
bridge for less than three point five
yeah but there's multiple bridges in
fact okay well we can do it for less
than three point five trillion but they
don't make the transportation's only one
point five trillion to be fair okay and
trump supported that as well but yeah
digress okay on your point if all if the
roads and bridges need fixing then why
can't these far left regressives get on
board and vote through this
infrastructure package then if this is
such a need this is as you pointed out a
bipartisan package so they should get on
the stage i agree with that i find this
whole thing i love watching a good cat
fight kennedy knows that
but this is like watching some chicks
pulling each other's hair out in the
parking lot while the gas and sips
getting robbed at gunpoint behind you oh
and the entire neighborhood's getting
robbed really the entire country that's
what this looks like nancy pelosi is
most concerned with how this is going to
look
of a few weeks from now keeping the
house in session overnight so today's
still thursday in case they vote on the
infrastructure or saturday is going to
be thursday
in the meantime
how about we this never happens that's
the win this country does not need any
of this
build back better
reconciliation spending at all people
are talking about one and a half
trillion dollars from joe manchin in his
letter that he sent over the summer is
some paltry amount brian riedel at the
manhattan institute went through the
numbers based on everything that joe
manchin has voted for this year it's
actually five trillion dollars in
spending one and a half trillion was the
last tax cuts that we passed and if you
go through joe biden's idea that the
left hates so much it's raising
corporate taxes raising the top rate
back to about 40 percent raising capital
gains tax rates
and that destroys the economy it doesn't
help it grow it hurts small businesses
that are struggling mightily to recover
from the pandemic just one more thing
bernie sanders in that tweet two
senators cannot be allowed to defeat
what 48 senators and 200 and 10 house
members want
it it's 52 comrade
not not two it's 52 senators versus 48 a
fundamental
misunderstanding from sanders of civics
and mass that's who wants to spend your
money dan and bernie made pelosi look
pretty dumb yesterday basically pulled
the rug out from her she said they were
going to have a vote they didn't have it
because bernie told the far left squad
don't do it absolutely not do not vote
for this infrastructure has to be tied
to the 3.5 trillion which is a starting
number that's the floor that's not the
ceiling joe manchin didn't build this
house can you do the rest of the show
like that please yeah that's because i
know it's it's a big turnout for a lot
of people um
richard the thing i take issue with is
this idea uh this obsession with things
like high-speed rail because other
countries have it you know what other
countries have they have unfunded debts
that they can't pay off and then they
enter into
areas of austerity where they have to
cut social spending and it ends up
hurting the people that they claim
they're going to help and to degen's
point when you raise the corporate tax
rate when you raise the tax rate for the
the top income earners uh you
dis-incentivize
economic growth and when you do that you
have less capital that means fewer
businesses can invest in the economy and
that means fewer people are going to get
jobs so when you contract the economy by
overspending with no way of paying for
it you know who gets hurt the most the
people you purportedly are trying to
help with massive pieces of social
legislation like this and this is a bill
this legislation it's a series of
programs that can never be on wrong so
if we enter into another pandemic or a
war or if there's an act of terrorism
that we can't respond to because we
don't have any more economic flexibility
what are the progressives going to do
about that well i think it's worth
pointing out that uh yes the earlier
this year do you want to do you want to
build high-speed railways like china
so earlier this week jerome powell the
federal chair federal chairman federal
chief of reserve sat down with other
chairman reserves from around europe and
they were talking about inflation what
he said very clearly is the reason why
we're the world is in inflation is
because we have supply chain problem
part of that supply chain problem has to
do with bottlenecks at many of our ports
in the united states this transportation
bill the 1.5 trillion will send
well-needed money to update ports
including the ports in long beach the
ports in miami the ports in virginia
beach the ports right here in new york
city updating these ports if we're
talking about long-term and we're
talking about long-term economic growth
then let's talk about how we update our
ports and move goods and services you're
actually small businesses all across the
world is wants to keep his job in
february so he's going to pair it which
is everything that's coming out of the
white house literally
all the treasury secretary but it's also
european european central bank leaders
global central bank leadership and
you're saying they're all wrong wait let
me just say you're an economist we need
to spend money to tame inflation that is
that is idiocy personified no i'm saying
we monetize our systems
and services we do have to go we do have
to go i just want to point out that the
democrat at the table is citing european
central bankers no i'm citing the name
as the authority as the authority on
economic growth this is nonsense
what else crap i just told you you're
not the only guy saying that you take
the l